like regular young people like they go
through Society thinking the pay Gap is
real they go through Society thinking
women are oppressed they go through life
literally believing these things and I
know because I talk to them but that's
as long as time when there were Kings
and Sultans all big up on the hill in
the castle they would send down the
people to scream War famine blah blah
scare people really well yeah why
because it's the same thing as Fox and
CNN trick all the stupid people the
Sheep they call it the one percent for a
[__] reason we need these people to
be stupid a lot of the times or at least
you know what they're not even stupid
they just don't look for themselves